et on accueille en direct notre entité
politique guillaume pelletier bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous porte
parole bégaiement vice président de son
parti reconquête on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par denis carot le
directeur de rédaction de nice-matin
brawn
on va évidemment parler de l'actualité
d'abord la crise sanitaire puisque
aujourd'hui marque un tournant dans les
protocoles sanitaires fini le palais
national fini le masque obligatoire sauf
dans les transports et à l'hôpital et ce
malgré un rebond de l'épidémie est ce
que pour vous le gouvernement fait un
pari risqué est ce qu'ils aiment raison
maintenir son calendrier malgré les
chiffres ont d'abord enfin
enfin la liberté
après deux années terribles pour notre
peuple et donc c'est un jour heureux
à ce titre même si au delà des questions
des courbes qui m'ont tous qui
descendent pour moi le et avec eric
zemmour le sujet clé c'est ce que nous
serons capables de tirer les leçons de
cette crise est à mon sens il y en a 3
qu'avec les risées mots nous avons tiré
et nous faisons des propositions d'abord
le rapport que la france entretient avec
nos soignants et notre système
hospitalier il est temps d'augmenter les
salaires et la rémunération de celles et
ceux qui s'engagent pour protéger et
soigner d'une part deuxièmement la
wii enfin vous savez moi j'ai j'ai été
maire je suis député de loir et cher je
suis conseiller départemental de
chambord j'ai été à ce titre président
de marc pas au départ vous savez ces
entités de soins ou d'accompagnement
pour la retraite suis très marquée
d'abord par le dévouement incroyable de
ces milliers et milliers d'hommes et de
femmes qui s'occupent des plus fragiles
des plus vulnérables d'une part et par
leur désarroi y compris après le fameux
ségur parce que ça ça semblait marginal
mais on souhaite une augmentation très
nette de 10 % de la rémunération
vénération des soignants des infirmiers
et des infirmières de tous ceux en fait
qui passent leur temps de manière
remarquable à travers cette belle
vocation de ce qui s'occupait des eaux
deuxièmement la question de la
bureaucratie on a bien vu combien la
france pour réagir à l'épidémie était
lente très lente trop lente et donc nous
proposons nous par exemple avec eric
zemmour la suppression des ars ces
fameuses à gyan agences régionales de
santé qui ont ralenti
l'efficacité de notre de notre système
et puis enfin tout le monde en parle
enfin 40 années de classe politique nous
ont conduit à ce déclin sur le principe
de la souveraineté de notre indépendance
rappelons-nous pendant des années en
tout cas deux ans nous avons été
chercher au bout du monde des masques
des tests des vaccins et donc l'urgence
aussi c'est de retrouver et c'est ce
qu'incarne eric zemmour pour le coup
depuis 30 ou 40 ans ce principe de
souveraineté d'indépendance de
localisation de ce qui fonde
coûte candidats dont emmanuel macron r
oui à une grande différence et quels
modèles macron et président de la
république depuis cinq ans et qu'il a
échoué dans ce domaine qu'il fut le
principal conseiller de françois
hollande qui lui même avait échoué dans
ce domaine et je pense que ceux qui ont
gouverné pendant 40 ans sont
disqualifiés pour donner des leçons aux
français sur la question la souveraineté
c'est tout le sait le coeur si vous
voulez de notre programme avec eric
zemmour s'est retrouvé l'indépendance la
puissance et la grandeur de la france
comme à l'époque du général de gaulle
c'est à dire une france indépendante qui
est capable de faire face aux grands
défis du monde
oui guillaume pelletier l'offensive
russe sur l'ukraine ne faiblit pas on a
vu hier des frappes beaucoup plus à
l'ouest à une trentaine de kilomètres de
la pologne les civils sont toujours
autant toucher ce qu'il faut monter d'un
cran supplémentaire les sanctions
alors tout ce qui fait part ferait
partie de sanction dite dissuasif pour
contraindre l'admirent poutine à venir à
la table des négociations
oui tout ce qui s'apparenterait à des
sanctions boomerang c'est à dire qu'ils
finiraient par abîmer la prospérité et
on le voit de notre peuple évoquer quel
type de 100 ch alors justement on
analyser ce qui s'est passé vous savez
on l'a tous commenté voulait les
premiers à versailles ces derniers jours
on était tous évidemment heureux de voir
l'europe unie sur la question
ukrainienne on peut regretter tout de
même comme l'a très bien fait d'ailleurs
dominique de villepin ces dernières
heures
l'europe est impuissante
l'europe a été impuissante à empêcher
cette guerre elle semble aujourd'hui
hélas impuissante à pouvoir l'arrêter
nous ce que nous demandons ce que nous
proposons depuis le début c'est que la
france
qui à cette vocation universelle qui
aimante je le rappel du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies s'appuie sur
la chine sur israël qui vous le savez
mène des négociations pour permettre
enfin cessez le feu et pour obtenir un
cessez le feu vous savez il faudra
aboutir à un compromis c'est-à-dire
évidemment ne rien céder sur l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine et le retrait
immédiat des troupes russes et puis
aussi la question vous le savez villepin
a évoqué aussi avec beaucoup de
précision de l'otan c'est à dire
garantir
hanon extension de l'otan vers l'est et
l'ajout de s'appuyer sur la chine parce
que ce matin les etats-unis s'inquiètent
du fait que la russie a demandé de
l'aide à la chine même si les états unis
ne connaissent pas la réponse de la
chine pour vous on peut s'appuyer sur la
chine dont je compris à vous savez moi
je suis avec eric zemmour nous sommes
très gaulliste ou gaullien le général de
gaulle avait par exemple reconnu
rappelez vous un an les années 60 la
chine vous savez quand on est une grande
nation du monde comme l'est la france en
tout cas de deux traditions l'un des
cinq membres du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies la seule voix le seul
chemin possible nicolas sarkozy l'a
rappelé à des mots forts avec des mots
forts à sa sortie de l'elysée il ya
quelques semaines c'est la diplomatie et
pour parvenir à une solution
diplomatique
il faut s'appuyer sur toutes les nations
du monde qui aurait pensé il ya quelques
semaines qu israël dont on ne peut pas
dire que chacun connaissait là la
vocation diplomatique pour le coup
serait à la manoeuvre pour permettre à
la russie et à l'ukraine de discuter
enfin l'enjeu clé il est là et donc
plutôt que des opérations de
communication
parfois un peu malheureuse d'ailleurs
comme les images qu'on a eu à versailles
a beaucoup été voté de la communication
ba aujourd'hui
nous avons espéré avec eric zemmour
jusqu'au bout que non mais force est de
constater que c'était il ya eu des
effets d'annoncé mais qu'est-ce que ça
ça a accouché de quoi est-ce que depuis
ce week-end enfin vladimir poutine et
monsieur est un ski discute grâce au
sommet de versailles est-ce que emmanuel
macron a pris des initiatives que le
plan digues l'eau diplomatique on ne
voit pas encore le décorum versailles le
palais des glaces c'était une erreur
en tout cas le faste quand il est aux
services de l'outil diplomatique peut
être utile mais comme l'a rappelé là
encore pardon de le citer mais enfin
j'ai trouvé très intéressant hier soir
dominique de villepin qui a quand même
cette expérience est moins en tout cas
pour ma génération vous savez on a sur
le plan international on a trois modèles
le général de gaulle bien sûr nicolas
sarkozy en 2008 qui lui avait su régler
la crise
géorgienne et puis dominique de villepin
et jacques chirac en 2003 qui était
monté à la tribune des nations unies
pour dire non aux états unis sur la
guerre en irak et donc j'écoute
dominique de villepin et il a dit très
précisément que ce faste là à ce moment
là pour aboutir simplement une opération
de communication c'était pour le moment
un aveu d'échec il ya une mesure qui a
été prise notamment à verser c'est
l'union européenne qui a doublé son
enveloppe pour les livraisons d'armes à
la à l'ukraine elle est passée de 500
millions à 1 milliard est ce que pour
vous c'est une bonne chose est-ce qu'il
faut livrer des armes et l'ukraine or je
ne suis pas un spécialiste géopolitique
nous notre ligne elle est très simple
elle est très clair tout ce qui permet
la désescalade tout ce qui permet de
contraindre la russie à venir à la table
des négociations donc bien sûr des
sanctions par exemple sur les hiérarques
russe ça ça peut être une solution
d'ailleurs qui a été utilisé mais
surtout la discussion ne jamais rompre
le fil de la digue seulement
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on peut
contraindre vladimir poutine à venir à
la table des discussions vous avez le
sentiment qu'il est ouvert et les 10
mais je pense que compte tenu d'abord
des sanctions économiques et financières
quand même qui monte d'un cran chaque
semaine de la situation en ukraine
aujourd'hui basée la diplomatie c'est
l'espoir tous les matins et tous les
soirs d'y parvenir et sur chaque guerre
on voit combien ce sont ces efforts qui
finissent par être payant et donc la
france doit être la nation leader sur la
diplomatie et oui plutôt que les
va-t-en-guerre comme les américains de
s'appuyer sur la chine et israël qui eux
ont choisi fait il faut penser à tous
ceux qui souffrent à tous ceux qui
meurent à ces familles qui sont dans la
aujourd'hui dans la dans le malheur et
donc l'urgence absolue c'est la paix
eric zemmour veut tout faire vous avions
proposé nous vous savez un traité de
paix dès le début de la guerre autour
des deux piliers que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure le respect de la souveraineté
ukrainienne de manière absolue est la
garantie pour la russie que l'otan ne
s'attendrait pas à l'est la france
pourrait accueillir cinquante à cent
mille réfugiés ukrainien s'est en tout
cas les prévisions du gouvernement
jean castex a évoqué une capacité
d'accueil rapide de 30 milles
pour trente mille réfugiés est ce qu'on
doit accueillir sans limites sans
réserve tous les réfugiés ukrainiens
n'ont jamais sans limite d'abord vous
savez avant d'écouter nos désirs
l'accueil nous devons écouter leurs
besoins les besoins des ukrainiennes et
de leurs enfants et vous avez raison les
chiffres de ce matin sont d'ailleurs
terrible 2 millions 700 mille ukrainiens
ont fui ou sont en train de fuir leur
pays ce qu'ils nous disent à 99 9% c'est
il souhaite rester dans des pays
frontaliers roumanie hongrie pologne
pourquoi parce qu'elle elle souhaite ces
mères de famille restée au plus près de
leur père de leur mari de leur fils qui
combattent de manière héroïque pour la
liberté donc d'abord la priorité ce que
nous demandons est qu'eric zemmour c'est
que l'europe et la france accompagne
financièrement en particulier la la
pologne est par exemple ça n'est
toujours pas fait suspende vous savez
les sanctions qui visent la pologne sur
le plan européen pour aider
financièrement la pun ça c'est la
première étape la seconde vous avez
raison c'est d'être en capacité quand
des municipalités des associations des
français souhaitent accueillir des
ukrainiens ce qui est un vrai le succès
qu'on voit bien sûr que wii fit sur la
première solidarité je le redis nous
leur disons français je le vois moins
chez moi en sologne cdd les ukrainiens
en pologne en roumanie et en gris
ensuite ceux qui veulent voir ceux qui
veulent venir bien sûr pour ceux qui
veulent venir leur permettre un accueil
digne on voit d'ailleurs les taux sur 2
millions 700 mille ukrainien la france
aujourd'hui un je crois et gérald
darmanin l'a confirmé ces dix mille
réfugiés environ et la troisième
condition c'est d'être très prudents
vrai je dis pas sans limites le fil de
vos confrères du figaro ont révélé en
milieu de semaine qu'un tiers des
réfugiés ukrainien qui est harry qui
arrivaient en france étaient en fin de
compte de nationalité marocaine algérien
cyr contourner les filières de passeurs
utilisait la tragédie ukrainienne pour
faire entrer des migrants et donc moi je
demande au président nous demandons
président la république nous demandons
au ministre de l'intérieur pour que nous
puissions accueillir dignement nos
frères européens de l'est les ukrainiens
de suspendre immédiatement toute
l'immigration du sud parce que la france
ne veut pas accueillir tout le monde
robert ménard a dit vous l'avez sans
doute entendu était d'ailleurs sur ce
plateau regretter ses positions près
c'est donc notamment sur l'accueil des
réfugiés syriens où il avait notamment
fustigé
avec une affiche il arrive vous partager
ce point de vue c'est ses regrets ce que
vous avez compris mercred robert ménard
chacun a sa sensibilité
moi ce qui est bien et beaucoup marqué
en tout cas ma génération vous savez ces
jeux on a interrogé les français si on
interrogeait le peuple allemand
rappelez-vous 1 avec angela merkel sait
que hélas des jihadistes avait utilisé
la crise syrienne la guerre syrienne
pour là encore intégrer l'europe de
l'ouest et commettre des attentats donc
moi j'appelle chacun à la prudence je
n'oublie pas ce qui s'est passé au
bataclan et c'est combien tu es con oui
mais combien oui mais c'est des
minorités au rendez vous rendez compte
des conséquences là encore pour des
dizaines et des dizaines de familles
françaises le terrorisme n'a pas disparu
ne soyons pas naïfs et donc nous ce que
nous disons c'est oui pour l'accueil
digne dé nos frères ukrainiens
européen à la condition que nous soyons
en capacité de stopper
les autres voulaient toujours votre
position on va parler d'un autre sujet
c'est le pouvoir d'achat évidemment qui
continuait la préoccupation majeure des
français notamment la hausse des prix à
la pompe et jean castex a donc annoncé
cette remise de 15 centimes par litre
d'essence à partir du 1er avril vous
saluer cette mesure
à dijon c'est la moindre des jo d'avoir
le 1er avril j'ai pas trop compris en
termes de communication ça me semble
très tardif m enfin
général et ce gouvernement en
particulier devraient arrêter de prendre
les français pour des imbéciles
nous savons tous créés moi je vis en
sologne la voiture pour nous c'est pas
un choix c'est une obligation et ça
concerne des millions et des millions de
travailleurs nous savons tous
aujourd'hui quand on voit le leu leu leu
leu le coût de l'essence 1,2 euro 2e
d'euros 10,2 euros 30 même dans dans
certaines pompes il ya un euro 20 1
euros 25 en moyenne qui vont dans les
caisses de l'état dont 15 centimes sur
un euro 20 à 9 30 je dirais que c'est le
minimum nous avec eric zemmour on a des
propositions beaucoup plus claire et
beaucoup plus cohérente nous proposons
d'abord le blocage immédiat des prix à
la pompe au montant ou ses prix était
avant l'entrée en guerre c'est
d'ailleurs aux environs d'un euro 80
première étape ça n'est pas suffisant
deuxièmement nous demandons tout un plan
d'investissement sur l'indépendance
énergétique de la france et là je
j'accuse emmanuel macron avec françois
hollande d'ailleurs pendant dix ans
d'avoir fait perdre beaucoup de temps à
la france sur la question du nucléaire
alors maintenant macron redécouvre le
nucléaire annonce à la relance de
l'investissement sur des sur des
centrales heureusement que nous avons
eue le général de gaulle jacques chirac
et nicolas sarkozy sur la question du
nucléaire et que nous sommes un peu
moins dépendante les autres par exemple
sur la question du gaz russe et puis y
aura plein d'investissement que nous
prévoyons nous quand eric zemmour sera
président de la république sur
l'investissement sur les biocarburants
qui coûte beaucoup moins cher et qui
pourraient rémunérer nos agriculteurs
sur la question de la méthanisation chez
moi en sologne nous investissons depuis
pas mal pas mal de temps sur des entités
de méthanisation pour rendre
indépendante sultan énergétique nos
communes rurales d'un tiers du plan à
long terme voilà
je m'engage et au blocage des prix qui
coûterait combien du coût pour les
caisses de l'état mais le évidemment
quelques milliards de manière provisoire
la france avait fait en 1991 avec pierre
bérégovoy lors de la guerre du golfe est
beaucoup plus efficace en tout cas que
la mesure qui est aussi coûtera très
cher 1,2 milliard d'euros la mesure de
jean castex en tout cas dire aux
français qui travaillent et qui n'ont
pas d'autre choix que d'utiliser la
voiture que les pouvoirs publics les
entende ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
aujourd'hui et juste derrière questions
là dessus vous qui venez d'un territoire
rural voulait avéra ps que cette mesure
doit être impliqué de manière uniforme
sur tout le territoire où est ce que
pour vous il faut des différences entre
les territoires où les territoires
urbains sur 7 un centime c'est notamment
ce que disent les maires euros
franchement on sait très bien quand on
ceux qui habitent paris ont la chance
d'avoir des alternatives tramways métros
et rer ce qui n'est pas du tout le cas
chez nous donc je pense que oui la
priorité c'est la france des provinces
la france périphérique où la fin des
mesures différentiel pour vous et alan
turing
je vous donne un exemple très précis qui
me marque depuis quelques jours et
j'avais déposé des textes de loi sur le
sujet c'est la question du fioul
domestique on est je me sauve chauffe
moi-même au fût long nez au vison 3
millions de français le chauffage c'est
le fuel mille litres s'étaient 1200
euros environ avant la crise c'est
aujourd'hui 1800 euros vous imaginez le
coût monumental pour des milliers des
milliers de familles et nous demandons
là encore le blocage des prix sur ce
sujet et ensuite une réforme en
profondeur tels que je l'évoquais
l'instant on a vu hier soir encore les
images extrêmement violente des
manifestations en corse qui se succèdent
depuis l'agression d'yvon colonna à la
maison d'arrêt de d'arles
la situation aujourd'hui est est-elle
encore sous contrôle et que doit faire
l'êta gérard d'arman a annoncé qu'il se
rendrait sur place mercredi et jeudi
enfin
la question centrale d'abord toutes les
violences sont à condamner on n'obtient
jamais rien par la violence et nous nous
sommes du côté de l'ordre et de la loi
mais de tous les ordres et contre toutes
les violences il faut écouter les corses
les corses qu'est ce qu'ils disent je
parle pas des de ceux qui sont violents
moi je suis persuadé que les corses
considère qu'il est plus que
conciliables d'aimer l'identité corse et
d'aimer la france l'état français n'a
pas écouté les corses emmanuel macron
mais n'a pas écouté les corses vous
rendez compte ce qui s'est passé dans
cette prison moi je je je comprends
l'émoi du peuple corse et je ne parle
pas évidemment de la tragédie qu'a
commise yvan colonna un jihadiste en
prison pendant 8 minutes a pu massacrer
un autre prisonnier un jihadiste mais
qu'est ce que fait la france comment
fonctionne notre système pénitentiaire
et je sais pourtant le courage admirable
de notre administration
pénitentiaire de tous nos surveillants
et donc pourquoi la france n'est
toujours pas capable de mettre à
l'isolément de manière absolue ces
jihadistes c'est cette question qui est
posée aujourd'hui par a traversé
violence que nous condamnons bien
entendu et vous comprenez le silence du
gouvernement sur ce sujet un sur la
question la grèce et deux sur ce qui se
passe en corse c'est ça qui me marque le
plus et c'est sans doute ce que
demandent les corses c'est pourquoi le
miz l'intérieur le ministre de la
justice pourtant tous les deux si prompt
à occuper les plateaux de télévision
n'ont pas très vite donner une
explication condamné et et trouver des
solutions pour que d'abord ce que nous
demandons nous depuis longtemps les
détenus corses puissent être rapprochés
de leur famille en corse mais surtout
qu'on puisse éradiquer partout et pour
tous le terrorisme et le djihadisme nous
nous proposons isolement complet des
terroristes et des djihadistes et à
l'issue de leur peine leur expulsion
vers leur pays d'origine il faut qu'on
soit intraitable avec eric zemmour bien
comprendre nous terroriseront les
terroristes partout où ils se trouvent
on va parler de la campagne
présidentielle manuel ma compagne est
entré en campagne avec notamment une
mesure le report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 65 ans sur 9 ans
eric zemmour lui propose 64 ans est ce
que cette mesure d' emmanuel macron vous
pourriez quand même la soutenir voilà le
problème avec emmanuel macron c'est que
il a oublié qu'il avait été président de
la république alors moi je veux bien
l'écouter une fois une fois candidat
d'abord il picore à certain nombre de
propositions un peu à gauche un peu à
droite donc un manque d'imagination
incroyable on l'avait vu prendre sur la
question de la redevance sur la question
de la retraite moi je lui dis dis moi
quel est ton bilan je te dirai qui tu es
ou je te dirai si j'ai envie de te
croire il a été cinq ans président de la
république c'était sa grande promesse de
2017 pourquoi emmanuel macron ferai
demain ce qui n'a ni pu ni voulu ni su
fait rire donc je n'ai aucune confiance
en m nl macro est d'ailleurs en cet
instant à travers votre question je dis
bien aux français si vous voulez à
nouveau un un président bavard qui ne
tient aucun de ses engagements qui
continue à faire monter l'immigration à
faire baisser notre pouvoir d'achat
augmenter les taxes et les impôts à
faire l'exact contraire de ce qu'il
promet voté manuel macron c est l
inverse voulait un changement radical de
société défendre notre civilisation
sauver la france arrêter l'immigration
terroriser les terroristes baisser les
taxes et les impôts pour augmenter enfin
le pouvoir d'achat les salaires des
français il n'y a qu'une solution c'est
de voter eric zemmour il est là le grand
défi le grand duel de cette élection
présidentielle valérie pécresse a raté
son meeting au zénith est ce que eric
simon n'a pas raté son débat face à
varilhes et valérie pécresse jeudi
dernier bas c'était sans doute le rêve
de madame pécresse ou d'un certain
nombre de commentateurs mais les faits
sont têtus depuis trois jours les
sondages il y en a tous les jours il ya
eu 3 ils montrent une progression d'eric
zemmour et une baisse de madame pécresse
donc les français ont jugé jeudi soir et
j'en étais persuadé qu'ils ont vu entre
les deux une candidate centriste macron
compatible bomba qui rêve d'être
ministre de monsieur macron c'est le
droit de madame pécresse et donc il sait
pas vraiment ce qu'elle a dit jeudi soir
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a persuadé à elle
est un cas pas pardon quand on lui a
posé la question aux familles moi
j'étais numéro deux des républicains je
les rencontre et lui décembre à la voter
ma grande 17 c'est son droit à la
quitter les républicains en 2019 parce
qu'elle estimait que laurent wauquiez et
moi j'étais le vice-président de laurent
wauquiez nous étions trop à droite elle
a refusé de prendre en compte les idées
de monsieur ciotti et maintenant elle
fait un peu une campagne
plus à droite que moi tu meurs sauf que
personne personne ne la crois pas mais
tout bien compris qu'elle allait
rejoindre emmanuel macron et dans le
grand duel qui s'annonce verrait le 10
avril macron ces mots ans valérie
pécresse soutiendra emmanuel macron nous
notre chance et qu'on le sait qu'un
certain nombre de parlementaires et une
grande majorité des électeurs de droite
rejoindront le seul candidat de droite
qui est apparu lors de ce débat c'est
eric zemmour quand elle vous dit par
exemple que l'immigration zéro c'est pas
réaliste qui a besoin d'une immigration
économique dans ce pays notamment comme
aux agriculteurs à ce qu'elle n'a pas
raison non parce que valérie pécresse
c'est tout c'est l'archétype de la
politicienne ça fait des décennies qu'il
est aux responsabilités qu'ils
promettent un certain nombre de choses
et qui sont incapables de régler les
problèmes des français bien sûr que
l'immigration zéro c'est possible alors
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas
issue la danse un certain nombre de
domaines des amendements mais c'est cet
objectif sera tenu mondialisation 0 avec
des exceptions mais comme comme dans
tout vrai mais dans la vie heureusement
il y à la règle qui est une règle
absolue nous disons et qu'eric zemmour
c'est fini les 275 mille titres de
séjour accordés chaque année j'ai bien
dit chaque année je ne parle même pas
des clandestins dont la politique
politicienne des 40 dernières années sur
le plan des grattoirs en partie chez
nous y mettrons fin notre objectif ce
sera immigration zéro ça n'interdira pas
dans quelques cas spécifiques comme nous
l'avons dit band sur la question du
droit d'asile nous accueillerons par
exemple les combattants de la liberté
nous l'avons toujours dit avec eric
zemmour mais l'immigration zéro ce sera
la colonne vertébrale de notre politique
migratoire est ce qu'eric zemmour
envisage toujours de un grand meeting
spectaculaire au trocadéro comme nicolas
sarkozy en 2012 et comme françois fillon
2017 oui bien sûr lancé l'un d'eux enfin
on a prévu 20 il nous reste 27 jours
avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est nous allons nous
avons préparé toute une montée en
puissance quelques exemples d'abord ce
grand meeting populaire le plus grand
rassemblement populaire de cette
campagne présidentielle au trocadéro le
dimanche 27 mars au nahd et ont réussi à
sarko d'énergie grimaud non mais d'abord
ce sera ce sera une revanche et on
montrera combien au peuple de droite il
est possible quand nous nous rassemblons
parce que c'est ça l'originalité d'eric
zemmour il rassemble des électeurs
et républicains dont j'étais des
électeurs du rassemblement national avec
marion maréchal et tant d'autres en gros
eric zemmour est en train de
reconstruire un grand parti de droite
populaire comme le fut le rpf du temps
du général de gaulle où le rpr du temps
de jacques saucier juste sur les
déplacements pour vous dire la montée en
puissance nous nous organisons aussi
avec nos personnalités nicolas bay
stéphane ravier gilbert collard marion
maréchal dès mercredi tout un tour de
france 22 meetings régionaux avec la
presse quotidienne régionale et nous
commençons mercredi soir à orléans par
un meeting commun avec eux je ferais que
marion maréchal et justement les
personnalités
lab sgb retard il ya que des gens de
l'ancien rassemblement national vous
êtes à l'heure actuelle le seul à l'air
finalement avoir rejoint un réexamen est
ce que ça c'est pas un échec alors je
suis pas tout à fait le seul jean
frédéric poisson ancien député-maire et
l'air de rambouillet sébastien pilar
laurence rochât l'air surtout vous savez
ce qui est important au delà de ce que
nous sommes
personnalités symboliques regardez bien
les chiffres eric zemmour rassemble
aujourd'hui un tiers des électeurs de
marine le pen et un quart des électeurs
de françois fillon donc le seul qui a
été capable de rassembler des électeurs
aux parcours différents c'est eric
zemmour valérie pécresse pourquoi ça
marche pas c'est que les électeurs
indépendants de droite et du front
national ne veulent pas voter pour elle
pourquoi marine le pen à la ce plafond
de verre les électeurs des républicains
ne veulent pas voter pour elle
de trois points on va être restons d
avril elle est là depuis 15 ans mais le
bien sûr c'est un vote d'habitude le
seul qui a posé cet acte politique
majeur dans notre histoire politique
récente qui a brisé cette frontière
virtuelle ce cordon sanitaire de
division des droites c'est eric zemmour
et c'est d'ailleurs le moteur principal
au delà de son courage sa force et de sa
sincérité parce qu'il est tout sauf un
politicien c'est ce qui va expliquer sa
qualification au second tour le 10 avril
parce que tous les électeurs de droite
sont les bienvenus autour d'eric zemmour
que vous ayez voté dans le passé le pen
sarkozy chirac pasqua villiers séguin
vous êtes les bienvenus chez eric
zemmour ça c'est notre différence avec
le pen et pécresse et ce sera de la fin
merci n'y sommes pas
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]